[Music]
you use put any person there we go cross
my legs to her
you can did yeah you can do whatever you
like I liked it you know whatever is
comfortable for you all right
Cassie Cassie where you from where'd you
grow up Virgil um I grew up in Modesto
California and tell me about your family
you had both your parents and you're a
kid July what did you have both your
parents when you grew up
no where was mom and dad mom and dad
were on drugs so my grandmother raised
Leigh
hey how was your childhood my childhood
was good yeah no abuse no crazy no
events no you know what kind of kid were
you in high school I think the high
school was your school yet um seventh
grade okay
where'd you go did you did you run away
earlier but I did run away and at some
point I kept getting into trouble when I
was going to school it was like a school
for Discipline kids so I went to that
school and I kept missing classes and
make some classes and missing classes so
they ended up taking me away from my
auntie who really really raised me and I
went to a group home on juvenile hall
and from juvenile hall my cousin had
came down there and said she'd take care
of me and when I went there I did good
for about four years and
I turned 18 so from there I went to my
mom my dad again who are drug users and
after that I started using drugs really
on the street at some point at some
point at then no at some point after a
while after that yeah yeah and the
transgender thing kind of kicked in for
you at what point when did you realize
that that was I've always felt like that
you're born that way I think yes yeah
did that caused problems with your
family or in school or anything like
that no no no um my family always
accepted me some of the guys in my
family would tease me because I didn't
play ball or anything but the most of my
family accepted my mom my dad the one
that raised me who I am there's a nice
view and where drugs a part of the
picture drugs has always been a part of
my picture what is it harder drugs start
for you um the first thing I did was
shot a used needle for heroin
at what age 13 13 and what are you using
today what am i using today well I'm
around the saying not today Saturday but
but in right now in 2020 20 okay right
now well I have something proud to say I
smoked crack for ten years straight
before I met my boyfriend and since I've
been with him I've been with him for 13
years I stopped smoking crack but two
years ago I came out Cisco and I started
smoking crack again and everything was
off the hook
all my whole life revolved around crack
and it was sad because I lost some of my
morals and respect for myself and others
and so I actually had
I had a client a date who gave me $4,000
and when I got that $4,000 I went and I
left everything I owned in an alley and
I just grabbed my dogs and my boyfriend
and we went to a motel and that's when I
stopped use him and I bought a car and
all that
what are you it's already using now what
am i using now oh I don't smoke crack no
more good for you so I like jam mixes I
like alcohol I like Cristal once in a
while and I like sex and you tell you
you work as a sex worker as well I am a
call girl yeah online buy mine and
you'll make how much in a night doing
this well last night I made 750 on two
dates two clients
very good and this morning I caught you
you so have you slept last night or
you've been up since I just woke up when
you saw me I just took a shower I was in
the wrong to the center I took a shower
and left and I was gone I was going to
buy me some eyelashes but I saw my
boyfriend and my dogs and he's a little
insecure so so you uh you you make
enough money that you can get a hotel
room for the night almost definitely
yeah so you know you're not living on
the street ya know and the guys that
will your customers will typically be
what kind of guys they're all types of
guys but you do get some like strange
requests and odd yes but I give it a lot
of good clients - from online because I
also prosecute out on the streets -
mm-hmm you been arrested before I've
been arrested before yeah and it's easy
for prostitution yeah
do you still have contact with you or
your aunt or your grandmother or anybody
my aunt I do she's trying to cancer I
have a sister I'm in contact with but
other than that no my mom my dad forget
my brother's dead all I have was my
boyfriend in my three dogs which one of
them got stolen by one of the drug
addicts around here you could you find
this lifestyle gets gets you down
sometimes you get depressed it does give
me dealing depressed sometimes but also
I enjoy some of it show
yeah are you due to do the lifestyle you
think I I am yeah I hear that a lot I am
are you saving money at all am i saving
money at all yeah poor I wish mm-hmm
I need to I just don't trust anybody to
give my money to and then once I get it
I'd go blow it I don't go blow it I go
and buy me clothes wigs yeah something
like that
how old are you I'm 38 actually my
birthday was just a few weeks ago I'm
Aries for 582 April as a transgender sex
worker do you I mean there's a
transgender do you find that you're kind
of almost forced into some kind of sex
work because you can't get a job I think
it's the easiest way because every job I
applied for they judge somebody and yeah
it's hard for you to get it yes very so
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing about transgenders for people that
are not from that world you get judged
very harshly right every day hmm I think
that they think that they're better than
me or that I'm a disgrace to the world
some people that talk crap to me is the
ones that really are struggling with
ourselves because they see me as sexy
and they see me as compelling in that
they might want to explore that Avenue
and it really messes with their brain
yeah do you get do you roughed up on the
street or do you get some kind of no you
take care of yourself yeah um I don't
take no BS I know a lot of people around
here and who has on my back yeah but
even if they didn't not have my own back
and have you been in love before in love
yes I am yeah I'm in love now with the
gentleman I saw you at the dogs yes I'm
gonna loved him for 13 years 13 years
that's great he allows you to do all
those stuff you're doing for money you
don't like it means a jealous mf'er no
but I pay the bills and I am he was
going in he met me doing this so I mean
yeah but he I feel sorry for him too
though cuz because he says I use this as
an excuse and sometimes maybe that's
true yeah are you generally would you
describe yourself as happy I am happy
yes you seem to be fairly but I can get
this up real quick and I have a bad
attitude because I was spoiled and I'm
always used to having the things that I
want and the things that I need
especially for men but our here in
Sanders cooks I'm from Modesto out here
in San Francisco people who are always
robbing people taking things from people
so I never get that opportunity to get
meet new people that are willing to
trust
do you think if you had a different
childhood that things may have been
different for you now maybe maybe you
know cuz I like a childhood yeah but it
sounds like you your parents were out of
the picture of early on yeah but I had a
decent caretaker and then something made
you bail out of school after seventh
grade yeah but I mean do you think if
you had stuck with school and maybe
graduated high school things maybe if I
wasn't on drugs and I was in the
prostitute I think I would want well I
wanted to be a model when I was younger
because I used to look a lot better than
I look now
I want to be a model but now if I think
I had all my stuff in control and under
life's terms then I would want to be I
don't know what it's called but you know
on Dateline in Nightline in 48 hours the
one talking behind the scene talking
about unsolved crimes or stuff like that
I would want to be one of those a
detective recently yeah what do you
think do you think your personalities
are things about you has changed from
all your years of living this lifestyle
yeah in what ways have you changed I
have a attitude sometimes I don't let
anybody get over on me or Punk me I'm a
little bit ruder not just some people do
people out on the streets because they
when they see I have money they all come
up bum-rush me can I get this can I get
that or I have a talkback go Taco Bell
okay I see going back to me and my three
dogs in my boyfriend can I get some can
I get some and it just likes to feel
like they do the same thing I do why
don't you go buy you some food too but I
just share our people also yeah what's
with the
toughest thing about your life right now
right now the roughest thing about my
life is one of my dog's got stall ding
and it's I got mom dad and daughter so
with the mom gone the other dogs are
very sad I'm just devastated as those my
boyfriend what's the most important
thing you've learned in what in life in
your 38 years
what's the most important thing you
think rarely trust anybody you and if
you want something done do it yourself
alright Cassie thank you so much for
talking with me and good luck with
wherever you go thank you thank you
you